ibram kendi the director of the center
for anti-racist research at Boston
University a man considered by Time
Magazine to be among the 100 most
influential people in the world has a
message for white people we white people
it turns out are not part of humanity I
don't think uh White uh people worldwide
have really reckoned with how much their
own personal identity is shaped by
constructions of
whiteness and and how
much um that construction of
whiteness uh
prevents uh white people from uh
connecting to humanity in other words uh
recognizing that uh when you when you
recognize that you are part and parcel
of humanity
in other words you're not over Humanity
right uh it it allows you
to really be able to connect to people
who don't look like you who have kinky
hair who have dark skin uh and to see
yourself in them and it's whiteness that
prevents that right and and when you're
not able to see
yourself uh in other human
beings that creates also s of
problems white people aren't human
that's the point for those who missed
kend's not so subtle argument white
people's race the race with which we are
born which we cannot change which not
even Rachel dozol can change try as you
might that prevents us from being human
because it prevents us from connecting
with Humanity which is just a a
euphemism it's just a flowery way of
saying
Being Human liberals love to Bandy about
that word dehumanizing in all sorts of
silly contexts here kendi is explicitly
dehumanizing all white people what kendi
is saying here is nothing more than the
pretentious clubbable version of the
sort of motos that black identitarians
are chanting in South
Africa K
kill to
kid kiss the bo the
farmer just the bo the
[Applause]
farmer
[Music]
attention shoot the boa shoot the farmer
that's Julius malma president of the
third largest political party in the
South African Parliament that's what
he's saying what he's saying sounds a
little dumber and cruder than what kendi
is saying the point is exactly the same
shoot the boa shoot the farmer these
people aren't human kend's not quite as
blunt but he is making the same argument
white people are not human therefore not
entitled to any human rights or any
political rights for that matter
political rights are only for humans the
only practical difference between the
two is that malma chance his
Psychopathic hatred at political rallies
in a failing African State and kendi
preaches his in Netflix screening Halls
to the Applause of the liberal
establishment Michael NS this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode's brought to you by good
ranchers head on over to good
ranchers.com and subscribe today with
code nolles K wle to claim your free
Limited stock holiday ham before it
sells out also major announcement to
start the show today lady Ballers is now
the most popular streaming movie on
Rotten Tomatoes our first full length
feature comedy is the biggest launch in
Daily wire history is now the number one
streaming movie in the country you can
watch it exclusively on dailywire plus
not a member well lucky for you code
coach will allow you to become a member
and save 50 bucks on new annual
memberships also we are breaking a story
on the show today we got a big big scoop
this is about PornHub and some of the
bizarre activities that they are up to
some of which were actually predicted on
this show you know I hate to say I told
you so incredible work undercover work
uh we've got video footage we will be
speaking with the journalist who
undertook that investigation in just a
little bit so stay tuned also lot of
announcements today also I will be at
Clemson later tonight I'll be in South
Carolina so if you're in the area I'll
post a link to how to reserve tickets we
will be discussing how kids are not
Commodities IVF and surrogacy so head on
over if you are in the area now on the
bright side of political activism Beyond
you know white people aren't human kill
the bow or shoot the farmer on the
bright side not only is Lady Ballers the
number one streaming movie on Rotten
Tomatoes we also made it to Capitol Hill
when Congressman Eric burles my friend
who has been on this show before you
might remember him uh was uh questioning
Riley G
a star of the lady Ballers movie on what
is going on with women's sports and the
agenda check it out I just want to say
you know to to Mrs Gaines what happened
to you was is tragic I mean the what you
were robbed of your the glory you were
robbed of your opportunity to um to be
clearly the Victor and it's if if it
weren't so tragic it would be comical I
mean and I understand there's a movie
being made that comedy about this very
issue um that on the daily wire that I
can't wait to see I encourage everyone
to watch it um and truthfully I think
that's what's needed uh because what
we're seeing again what myself and my
teammates and my competitors saw was a
mockery a mockery of women uh and I
believe it's time we mock the mockery
through comedy because you're right it's
objectively funny uh it's inherent to to
almost look at this and laugh because it
feels like satire uh but why watching
that movie uh to which I watched uh it
didn't feel like satire it felt like a
documentary of what again myself and
girls around the country continue to go
through thank you my time has expired
really important point from congressman
burles and of course from Riley
gains this is called a hearing
on transgenderism in women's sports the
the way that this has all been framed is
is about women's sports and that's a
little bit misleading I think
because no one actually cares about
women's
sports if this were just about women's
sports people would write it off and say
don't we have bigger issues in America
yeah maybe it's a little wrong the
hulking dudes running and and beating
the women but like who you know we're on
the brink of World War II we got a
migration crisis who cares about women's
sports no one even shows up to watch
them no one no one goes to WNBA games
it's it's a minor issue I agree with you
no one actually cares about women's
sports that's not what this is about
what this is about is
Justice no I'm not I've never gone to
see a women's basketball game and I
never will I don't I don't even watch
men's sports really very small number of
exceptions that's not the problem here
the problem is that these women have
trained their whole lives they were told
that there are rules to the game they
were told that if they worked really
hard they could win a trophy and they
could get some Glory that they could get
even material matal benefit from it they
could get scholarships they could they
could go to the College of their dreams
and then that is being stolen from them
by men who are breaking the rules of the
game that's what's so wrong that's how
you get someone like me fired up about
this I don't I don't care about women's
sports at all and most people don't but
you don't need to care about women's
sports to recognize that this is
terribly wrong and it's deeply unjust
and it's dangerous for women don't
forget when when dudes started fighting
in women's MMA what happened immediately
the dudes started cracking the women's
skulls this is terribly dangerous it's
terribly wrong everything about it is
absurd that's what makes it a comedy one
of the critical reviews of Lady Ballers
said this this movie is actually
undercutting its argument that we need
to save women's sports because the joke
in the movie is that no one actually
shows up to women's sports and they
start showing up when the men infiltrate
the games no that the argument of the
movie is not that we need to save
women's sports the argument of the movie
is we need to protect women and we need
to defend Justice that's the message of
the movie yeah the movie points out
people do want to go see men compete in
sports more than they want to see women
because men are bigger and faster and
stronger that's why it's so wrong to
have them running and swimming against
the women and certainly wrong to have
them punching the women in the face now
speaking of
women Liz Cheney has got a major all
most
announcement and I am totally here for
it right after we talk about expressvpn
right now go to expressvpn.com the
Advent season is a time of Joy gratitude
and reflection in the midst of the
festivities consider taking a moment to
reflect on the digital footprint that
accompanies you think about all the
information on your phone your searches
your location websites you shop out and
more companies can legally gather this
information and sell it for profit that
is why you need to do what I do and
Trust
expressvpn to protect your private data
expressvpn is an app on your phone and
computer it encrypts all of your online
traffic so your data stay private if you
think Incognito windows will stop people
from tracking your online activity read
the fine print that appears when you
start browsing in incognito mode it says
that your activity might still be
visible to your employer your school or
your internet service provider with that
Express VPN every site you visit could
be logged by the administrator of that
Network I love expressvpn because I'm a
big L out
and it's super easy to use the app has
one button once you turn it on you are
protected from prying eyes daily wire
has partnered with expressvpn to get you
a special Christmas offer go to
expressvpn.com
nkw and get three extra months for free
that is
expressvpn.com
slns expressvpn.com to learn more Liz
Cheney is floating a thirdparty run for
president real hard she's she's been
teasing this a little bit for the past
few months now there would seem to be a
coordinated effort you saw multiple
op-eds over the last week or so from Liz
Cheney and her allies in Washington
suggesting that Donald Trump could
become a dictator if he were to be
elected president again he is the
existential threat to the Republic and
so for the good of our country Liz
Cheney might run third party I think
that the situation that we're in is so
grave she says and the politics of the
moment require Independence and
Republicans and Democrats coming
together in a way that can help form a
new Coalition so that may well be a
third party option my first takeaway
here is that Liz Cheney does not know
the singularity or plurality of the word
politics politics is a singular noun so
it' be politics is anyway it's a minor
Point she doesn't know grammar but she's
knows how to save the whole country she
doesn't know how to get votes to be
reelected to Congress but she knows how
to save the Republic from Donald Trump a
very popular man and a very successful
president listen I'm for it I might
criticize Liz Cheney I hope she runs oh
boy would that be great I want Liz
Cheney to run I want Bobby Kennedy to
run I want Cornell West to run I want
them all to run
because none of these candidates take
votes from
Trump or rather I should say none of
these candidates take net votes from
Trump they will take more votes from
Biden than they will from Trump this is
reflect in most of the polls even for
Bobby Kennedy who is the closest to
sharing a base with Donald Trump and
even then most of the polls show he
pulls more from Biden than he does from
Trump Bobby Kennedy helps Trump get
elected Cornell West certainly helps
Trump get elected Liz Cheney how many
Liz Cheney fans we're going to vote for
Donald Trump but then we'll vote for Liz
Cheney if she's running zero there is no
overlap on that ven
diagram so I love it throw it all in
there baby why and why is that why is it
that candidates are having such a hard
time taking taking votes away from Trump
even in the Republican primary even
Ronda santis who has modeled his tenure
as Florida governor and his presidential
campaign on being Trump without the
baggage the bigger better version of
trump I like where Trump took the
Republican party but I'm going to do the
better version of it I'm going to wield
power more effectively I'm going to have
a clearer political Vision I that has
been the pitch for for Dan santis even
he has not really been able to cut into
the Trump support why is that
because Trump is is unique the guy is an
American original and he represents in
the mind of the voting
public a choice not an echo and all
these other people Liz Cheney even Bobby
Kennedy who's kind of a weirdo certainly
Joe Biden all the rest of them don't
none of them have been able to emulate
that I I don't know what Liz Chen is
thinking she probably just wants
attention because no one's giving it to
her anymore but but if
she really believes that running for
president is her best way to take down
Donald
Trump or whoever the Republican nominee
is but I guess she's really after Trump
bring it on baby go for it love it now I
mentioned that D santis who again have
to preface this really like the guy
think he's terrific has been an
excellent governor in another cycle he
could be an excellent presidential
candidate but his campaign has been very
lackluster this cycle he previously was
viewed as the anti-trump candidate some
of may have predicted that that was not
going to work because you can't be the
trumpy anti-trump candidate in his own
presentation he's Trump without the
baggage in the in the presentation of
his donors and just given his his place
in the race he has to be the anti-trump
guy and you can't be the trumpy
anti-trump guy it just doesn't work so
even though it seems like that would
make you the strongest candidate it
actually leaves you as a man without a
home and now the
anti-trump voters and donors especially
are moving toward a different candidate
that candidate would be Nikki Haley
because Nikki Haley though she might not
describe herself this way has always
been from day one the moderate in the
race she's been more of the Centrist in
the race and she's modeled basically her
whole political career on that line of
thinking and so the coch network is now
backing her some of the biggest donors
in GOP politics she's she's uh picking
up a a lot of support now among the
center right type among the
punditry and she's moderating some of
her positions including one that that
might really hurt her with the B uh
Nikki Haley is
suggesting that the government has no
place in the in the matter
[Music]
of speaking of the go GOP Presidential
field it is shrinking I teased this
yesterday
Doug bergham is out Doug bergham the
governor
of want to say Montana I don't even
really remember but I think it was
Montana he made a lot of money in Tech
or from Microsoft or something he also
was a a social liberal but he wanted to
cut taxes he seemed like a very nice guy
I know people who donated to his
campaign because if you gave him 10
bucks he would send you a $20 gift card
to some store so because he wanted to
qualify for the debate so anyway he's
out and I have to tell you people made
fun of me for suggesting that Chris
Christie would go further in this race
than uh a lot of people were
were believed that he would when I said
Christie he might he might have a moment
or you know he might he might stick
around for a while he might end up in
and people laughed chrisy he's the worst
candidate in the whole race hahaa well
look who's left it's four candidates
left at these debates DeSantis Haley the
vake and somehow christe does that mean
that we're on the brink of a croissance
uh maybe not croissance for short but
the man by knowing what Lane he's in
knowing that he is in the Centrist Lane
he's just an alternative to Trump that
man has stuck around a good long time
when he had no right to do it Ronda
santz is the best governor in America
and he got reelected by a huge margin
obviously that guy should still be in
the race Chris Christie left office in
disgrace and no one likes him anymore
and he and he's still in it the
croissants Perhaps it is actually
happening now when you've got some nice
delicious croissants sometimes you want
to put some good meat on it when you
when you want good meat you got to check
out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code NES what do
green eggs in your Christmas dinner have
in common they both need ham to be
complete not just any ham a spiral cut
Heritage pork Masterpiece from good
ranchers it's kind of ham that'll steal
the show at your family gathering and
you get it for free with any good
ranchers subscription that's it's a
whopping $99 value that you get for free
in your first order simply subscribe to
any box you will get your free Christmas
ham with any order the subscription is
phenomenal you get 25 bucks off every
order a free gift in every third box and
free shipping on express delivery best
part is knowing exactly where your meat
comes from that's a local American Farm
I have had good ranchers for two nights
in a row now and usually it's the juicy
steaks cuz I'm more of a red meat guy
but I had the chicken the last couple of
nights and it's just excellent it's just
the best chicken that I eat you know I I
sit down cuz Alisa she sometimes buys
other meat if we've gone through our
good ranches or whatever and I sit down
I take one bite whether it's steak
whether it's chicken what I say good
ranchers she says uh I say how did I
know how did I know because it tastes
excellent that's how I know head on over
to good ranchers.com subscribe today
with code nolles claim your free Limited
stock holiday ham before they sell out
Act Fast won't last forever order before
December 11th for guaranteed delivery by
Christmas goodranchers.com codee nolles
when you subscribe get a free 10 pound
holiday ham don't settle for the same
same old holiday Fair go to good
ranchers good ranchers American Meat
delivered it's no question we're living
in an upside down clown World basic
Notions of right wrong Justice truth
even reality itself thrown out the
window totally defenestrated how are we
going to make sense of it all join
Jonathan Pou in the new four-part series
end of the world as he explains why the
world as we know it is ending how to
survive it and how we can plant the
seeds for the next world today Jonathan
Pou is an iconographer he's a public
speaker YouTuber good of Jordan Peterson
a pal of mine as well even though he's
one of those Eastern Orthodox types he
still he still has a thing or two to
teach you uh you might remember him from
his profoundly Illuminating comments in
Jordan's series on Exodus well now he's
back he will drw on his deep knowledge
of Christian tradition stories mythology
and history to explain the
contradictions in our society wacky
phenomena and how this pattern will
reach its conclusion in end of the world
you will receive a thoughtful framework
to make sense of these confusing times
and a road map to lead us out of the
clown world and restore order the first
episode is available today exclusively
on dailywire plus if you haven't become
a member this is the perfect time
dailywire.com subscribe unmask the
Carneys and see beyond the end watch end
of the world
today now turning to the Democrat side
of the presidential race major Democrats
are souring on Joe Biden in fact Bill
Maher who he's sometimes unorthodox with
the left but he's generally a reliable
center- left guy he just came out on his
show and he said that not only is Biden
messing up Trump is actually right when
he talks about education he says he
under his administ under his
administration his next one schools will
teach students to love their country not
to hate their country like they're
taught now I got to say this one doesn't
bother me so much because I think that I
mean this is what I see when I see kids
demonstrating these Progressive
progressives demonstrating for H L the
most illiberal people in the world that
oh good we're going to give America it's
come up and America this is they kind of
have been indoctrinated this way and
Chuck Schumer made a speech this week he
said Andy s is a five alarm fire that
must be extinguished this is the highest
ranking Jewish politician we've ever had
in this country he talked about when
Jewish people hear chants like from The
River To The Sea do you understand that
means wipe us out by any means necessary
that Trump is right when he says that
the schools teach people to hate America
that's obviously
true obviously true now what does this
mean for us does me does this mean that
uh Bill Mah is a right-wing Republican
now no he's not does it mean that the
right should suck up to Bill Mah as we
sometimes do uh no I don't think we
should do that Bill Maher is the perfect
mainstream Center left
guy he's a great example of that guy and
so the use of Bill Mah for Republican
itical purposes is as a
barometer and the bill Mah barometer
reading here is telling us something
that a lot of us have seen for years at
this point which is that the education
issue is great for
Republicans the cham of Commerce types
the squishes the forget about social
issues types they don't want to talk
about that oh no just leave it to the
parents and the local communities and
don't let's not talk about what's being
taught in the schools let's not taught
about the ideologies foed on little kids
let's just let's just ignore that no
bill m is saying man these schools
they're teaching kids to hate America
what's wrong with these
guys yeah the education issue got Glenn
yunan elected in Virginia it was related
to
the an education issue but it got Glen
yunan elected that education issue was
one of the biggest drivers to get Ronda
santis reelected in Florida Ronda santis
going in taking over a school a big lib
School the what is it new College of
Florida going in hostile takeover
filling it up with conservatives
changing the curriculum so it stopped
teaching anti-American nonsense and
started being a serious educational
institution great love it why why is
this such a good issue because everyone
has kids that are in some kind of
schooling or another because during Co
parents for the first time saw the kind
of nonsense their kids were being taught
which led to a huge Spike in
homeschooling because the left has
turned parents into a unified political
group for the first time ever it's a
great issue any Republican who wants to
win needs to run on this issue it
appeals to so many people this issue
appeals to Suburban moms in the midwest
it appeals to recent Muslim immigrants
in Dearborn Michigan It app no one wants
their kids to be taught this lunacy in
schools great issue it even appeals to
Bill Mah now speaking of Bill on a
different episode of his show Roseanne
Bar who I think I can now refer to as my
colleague because that's pretty great I
I want to put that in my Twitter bio
colleague of Roseanne Bar because
Roseanne is going to be the voice in our
show burum Mr burum Adam corolla's
cartoon that that we're producing here
at the daily wire that is absolutely
terrific I've seen the pilot it's it's
amazing so Roseanne goes on Bill Mars
Show and she makes pretty weighty
accusation about him no wonder I don't
remember this no you blocked it out M K
Ultra who's that that's the mind control
program you're under Bill MK Ultra yeah
so who's but who's CLA Schwab the head
of the
WF what's
that Google
it love Roseanne she's great Google
it now people are looking at this clip
they're saying man Roseanne's crazy
isn't she she's always been a little
crazy she said she's a little crazy most
comedians
are here though Roseanne doesn't really
sound like the crazy one to me Ro
Rosanne comes at you says Bill you're
under an MK
Ultra mind control program MK Ultra was
was that program of the CIA to try to
control people's minds it's also my
preferred nickname I really like I'm
going to rename my show MK Ultra I think
that's really
great okay that's a big crazy wild
accusation but the crazier thing
is bill says he doesn't know what it is
he's never heard of MK Ultra MK Ultra of
all of the nefarious CIA operations over
the years operation Mockingbird all
Northwoods right all the rest of them MK
Ultras by far the most prominent
well-known program Bill Maher is
seriously saying he's never heard of MK
Ultra then she goes she she cuts in
later in the interview she's talking
about the world economic forum and CLA
fob CLA fob everyone's heard of clash
fob not everyone not everyone there are
plenty of people who have never heard of
clob but anyone who pays attention to
political news at all has heard of clab
Bill Maher has been doing a political
news and commentary and comedy show for
what 30 years now in some form or
another he's never heard of clou fob and
then she clarifies she says you know
from the WF the world economic Forum he
says what's that he's never heard of the
world economic
Forum what's going on here is Bill m
actually MK ulted I don't
know is what does it even mean to be MK
ultr does it mean you're just a super
fan of the show I don't know but don't
tell me Roseanne's the crazy one in that
interview I assume bill is just playing
dumb if he's really never heard of those
things I well strange maybe he's under
some mind control now speaking of the
deep
State we hear at the dailywire we cannot
stop suing the Biden Administration we
just love it it's one of our favorite
hob IES and this is breaking news it
just came out we are suing Biden's State
Department this is a lawsuit with the
Federalist and with the state of
Texas uh we are suing the state
department because we now have very
strong evidence that the state
department spent money to destroy our
business the US state department which
is tasked only with dealing with foreign
affairs
which is prohibited from wielding its
power
on domestic issues certainly against
domestic perceived enemies the state
department used its money to destroy the
daily
wire how did they do that they used
government
money they then within the state
department turned the global engagement
Center which is an office designed for
countering foreign terrorist propaganda
and they turned it on so-called
disinformation in the United States this
is a blatant violation of the First
Amendment they uh the gec this this uh
Center to counter foreign terrorism in
fact it was founded as the center for
strategic counterterrorism
Communications was tasked with
disrupting the communications of
al-Qaeda then Congress uh clarified in
2016 that none of the funds authorized
for the entity quote shall be used for
purposes other than countering foreign
propaganda and then what happened the
gec turned its focus onto US unto
Americans They promoted Pro censorship
leftist organizations such as News Guard
and the global disinformation index were
considered one of the worst offenders on
the global disinformation
index and and newscard hates us too
though and they try to censor us as well
and then they used that money to destroy
our business and not just us to destroy
the Federalists to destroy the New York
Post to destroy reason magazine reason
magazine they're just some amiable pot
smoking Libertarians they're going after
reason too reason is barely it's hard to
even call that right-wing it's vaguely
right-wing State Department going after
them too so we are suing them we love
suing the Biden Administration we've got
a pretty good track record suing the
Biden Administration so I think it's
going to work out very well and right
now in in DC the the Deep state does not
seem quite as omnipotent as it once did
they seem kind of blundering I'm
beginning to get the impression of the
deep State not that they are truly the
shadowy cabal of five people controlling
the whole world I'm starting to get the
sense that it's like Burn After Reading
by the Cohen Brothers that everything
they touch turns to Ash because they're
extraordinarily incompetent and they
have bad motives as well like trying to
destroy our business with money that
that's supposed to be used to disrupt
foreign terrorists they've got bad
motives too I'm not denying that but
they're just so profoundly incompetent
they use money to try to destroy us
every time they do it our company
doubles in size now we have the biggest
comedy movie in the country on Rotten
Tomatoes keep it up State Department
while we sue you for this keep it keep
spending more money to destroy us I
think by the end of it we're going to be
the biggest media company in the world
now that would help me sleep easy at
night when you want to sleep easy you
got to check out beam right now go to
shop beam.com are you struggling to
sleep at night did you know that poor
sleep can cause weight gain mood issues
poor mental health and lowered
productivity sleep is the foundation of
our mental and physical health and
performance you must have a consistent
nighttime routine to function at your
best if you are struggling with sleep
you got to check out Beam Beam is
designed to help you fall asleep stay
asleep and wake up refreshed beam's
dream powder contains a powerful
allnatural blend of ingredients
including magnesium L theanine they sent
some dream powder to the studio for our
team to try and everyone says that beam
is helping them fall asleep and stay
asleep unlike regular sleeping pills
that will make you wake up feeling
groggy beam helps you wake up refreshed
just mix beam dream into hot water or
milk stir or froth and enjoy before
bedtime today our listeners can get a
special discount on beam's delicious
dream powder they're bestselling hot
cocoa for sleep with no added sugar now
available in delicious flavors like
cinnamon cocoa and chocolate peanut
butter better sleep has never tasted
better triy beam's bestselling dream
powder take advantage of their biggest
sale of the Year get up to 50 % off for
a limited time when you go to shop
beam.com noes discount is auto applied
at checkout no code necessary shop Beam
bam.com
kwl for up to 50 % off today my favorite
comment yesterday is from mes ginta what
a name who who says the speed in which
Michael does his ads makes me wonder how
well he could rap I challenge you sir
production team do your thing
hey I am Wonder Mike and I've come to
say hello to the black to the White the
red and the brown the purple and yellow
but first I got to get to our
guest this is a breaking news story uh
I'm really pleased that we were able to
uh get this story and we did not do the
investigation this investigation was
undertaken by a a wonderful uh News
Group this would be sound investigations
I am joined here by one of the
journalists ardan young ardan thank you
for coming on the show thank you so much
for having me AR before we get into how
you conducted this investigation what it
all means I want to just show people
some clips of of what you've uncovered
because some of us have suspected that
PornHub and its parent company formerly
called mindgeek now it's called Alo they
have to keep changing the name because
they're an evil company and they they
don't want to have to uh face the music
some of us have suspected that they've
been up to these kinds of activities for
a while here it is in their own words
let's say you're 12 years old you're
still figuring out your sexuality maybe
even your
gender wouldn't it be helpful to
see not a celebration but just like
maybe a normalization of something that
you think is what you want you know
probably helps a lot let's say I was 12
and I saw like trans angels I saw all
these different sites it would help me
figure out what I do like and what I
don't like they need
to try to push stuff that's more less
less accepted like putting a putting a a
trans male or trans female in a scene
you wouldn't get that on a normal
mainstream site so test it out see if
you get a bigger audience with it see if
you can convert somebody right like
maybe somebody who's never look for
anything like that might find an
interest they click on it same thing for
buy stuff same thing for gay that's
another senior script writer at mindgeek
now called Alo but we all know it as
PornHub that's just the biggest
pornographers on the
planet
two major discoveries here one they they
know that kids are looking at their
content they're totally fine with it it
obviously helps their business model we
all knew that it's crazy to hear it in
their own words we all knew that the
second Discovery to me is the most
shocking senior script writer here at
the biggest porn company on Earth saying
yeah we're trying to convert straight
guys into looking at gay porn or porn
we're always trying to push the
boundaries we're not even just serving
the market that already exists for porn
we're trying to create new markets by by
creating new Desires in people that they
do not previously have that are
certainly out of the mainstream that are
considered more deviant and and we're
going to slip that content into the porn
to to expand the pallet I suppose of the
customer I can't believe they're
admitting this I know I mean I I was
hitting across from him that was
probably one of the last things I was
expecting him to say um I my instincts
were to just ask him about the the kinds
of things they were marketing to people
because I knew he does primarily work on
gay and trans pornography sites that's
mainly what he writes and um he was very
very open was very matter of fact and
and in fact he like you saw he even
viewed kids viewing porn as a positive
thing so you you're conducting this
interview this guy obviously has no idea
what's going on but you'd
think if if you were working for so
degenerate a company a and you were
engaged in such even today frowned upon
kinds of behaviors you might be a
little a you might play it a little
closer to the vest right he didn't
though did it take much prodding or was
he just open about this he was extremely
open about this and this we're talking
about Dylan in particular the senior
script writer for Alo um he was
extremely open extremely obliging did
not think my questions were strange or
out of place at all um and it goes to
show you kind of the mindset these
employees of this company are in porn um
in all of its forms are so normalized to
them and they're so callous to something
as serious as a child being able to view
pornography but of course we all know
and in fact in one of your interviews
you you mentioned that the the median
age of exposure to pornography now for
kids is something like 11 frankly I'm
surprised it's that high I I I would
even suspect it might be lower maybe
today it is lower we all know that kids
are accessing porn and that's how the
porn companies cultivate and groom their
their future crop of customers because
kids brains are very very malleable if
they get addicted to this stuff when
they're 10 or 11 years old they're going
to stick with it for a very long time
most likely again it's horrifying they
should be prosecuted for it it's just
evil it's great to hear them admit
it the thing that is so shocking to me I
guess is that we have been told for my
entire life by the left by the the pro
pornography people by the sexual
revolutionaries that sexual desire is
innate and immutable it's an
orientation nobody
becomes gay bisexual it's not you you're
just you're born that way and how dare
you suggest how I we'll probably be
kicked off of social media for even for
even repeating what this top porn
employee is who writes the stuff who
know knows what he's talking about what
he is admitting on camera we'll probably
be be kicked off even for repeating it
but but what he is saying is yeah no
that's all bunk actually yeah you can
convert people that's how our business
model works you got to slip in this
weirder stuff so you take a guy who's
been straight As whole life who's never
entertained any other kind of thought
and then you try to get him well
actually you went even in Greater depth
uh with him let's play that clip the
thing is is like when you write for like
Sean Cody is like primarily gay targeted
when you write for Trans Angels was
trans uh female presenting targeted you
also try to see how much you can take of
that and bring it to mainstream vanilla
content right cuz like brazers and
Reality Kings is predominantly for
straight men but you try to like push
the envelope as much as you can be like
okay can I hint at like buy content here
can I can I like talk more about like
what if we brought a trans Talent onto
the site
and you kind of like take those risks to
try and dra it a little bit more even
though you know that you have a site
dedicated to that right you're always
trying to push a little cuz the thing is
the thing about trans Angels which is a
site um it's female presenting trans
women it's and like they sell that to
straight men like that's the
demographic there it is there's they are
they're trying to the straight guys I
mean that that's not my words don't hey
hey social media companies don't take me
off for saying that that's with the
senior writer at mindgeek the guy who
writes all of this porn he is saying we
are trying to take straight guys our
Target demo is converting straight guys
into yeah and you know I think I think
he meant convert in the marketing sense
which doesn't really make it any better
it's the same s concerned about yes I
there's a whole conversation we had
about the business model and capital ISM
but it when we're talking about a
product that involves at a very deep
level your own desires and your own
identity then when you convert people to
the product you're converting them in
their desire and their identity
exactly exactly and I think they're
completely motivated by profits they
just want to make more a wider variety
of content more palatable and um more
profitable to the single viewer
um and you know going back to Children
accessing pornography we're seeing more
and more ID laws PED in the US so now in
many states it's required to verify your
age before entering a pornographic site
um Alo and the parent company of PornHub
is actively suing some of these US
states trying to stop this from
happening because they openly admit that
requiring their ID before accessing porn
actually drives down their traffic by
80% so for them protecting children is
not a concern maximizing profits is 100%
their concern and they don't seem to
care who they harm in the process of
course not I thought it told the whole
story when Utah first pass I think it
was Utah passed that that uh ID law and
instantly PornHub said okay we're not
doing business in the state of Utah
anymore you said well there you go there
there you have it uh Arden can you stick
around for a little bit we've got to end
this portion of the show we will go into
the member block exclusively for the
dailywire members but there's so much
more that I want to ask you so you stick
around all right the rest of the show
continues now head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe if you want more
of this breaking story exclusive story
from ardin and sound investigations and
so much more we'll see you
[Music]
there